a new safety tool could soon be
implemented to help minimize crime here
in las vegas it's called order out
corridor which is very similar to what
clark county recently approved along the
strip which would keep crime drugs and
prostitution out
a proposal to help keep crime down in
las vegas could soon be implemented
around the city it's called order out
corridor which would cover popular areas
like the fremont street experience and
the arts district i don't know how it's
going to be enforced and i don't know
how it actually solves the problem megan
linney is the founder of the layer
lounge on third street and is
questioning the idea which would
establish areas where a person convicted
of committing any crime within the
designated corridor be banned for a year
you live there you work there like
what's the chance of rehabilitation if
you strip someone of their like
community if they can't go to where
their friends and family are according
to the proposal the areas being
considered are from washington to sahara
i-15 to eastern the idea stems from a
similar effort clark county recently
approved for the strip but activists say
having a provision in general is
concerning fundamentally interferes with
basic constitutional liberties although
the proposal is aimed at people with
criminal backgrounds some say the
provision is too vague what happens six
months from now you don't know you're
going to pass through the area you're
driving and you're just going through
the area now you're violating the order
out provision linney says while the
concept isn't ideal she believes
something needs to be done we definitely
have
some nefarious characters but like
like violence we see a lot less of
well the city of las vegas tells us the
bill will not be discussed during the
next city council meeting which is
happening on september 7th now it will
likely go to a recommending committee
meeting then referred back to the city
council for action